our enemies certainly did not count on
it drawing our family closer together
Todd Chrisley admitting his and wife
Julie's fraud convictions only brought
them closer together God didn't bring us
this far to drop us off on the latest
episode of Chrisley confessions Todd who
said to report to prison with Julie by
January 17th explains how they're
dealing with the public ridicule I
believe that our pain has been placed
for the world to devour with so many
people wanting to see us fall right
wanting to see our destruction but what
they didn't count on was the power of
God they didn't count on it driving my
children closer to the Lord they didn't
count on the relationship that you and I
how how much deeper our relationship was
going to go they didn't count on the
healing that was going to take place
through their plan to destroy us
it's something Julie echoed last week
when chatting with Chase's fiance Emmy
Meadows on the podcast no matter what no
matter what the future looks like I feel
like that our family will continue to
strengthen absolutely and we will love
on a different level even yeah
and that that gives me hope
Todd and Julie are sentenced to a
combined 19 years in prison after being
convicted of tax fraud last June these
were very serious crimes the fraud was
extensive but what we will not do is we
will not break we made that commitment I
know I made that commitment that no
matter how tough things were I was not
going to walk away the reality of it for
me is when you know you did not do these
things and yet you sit you stand here
convicted
that's that's a hard pill to swallow
according to multiple reports the couple
was denied bail days before their prison
start date also denied the star's
request to delay their date to surrender
I would love to say it's all scripted
but you can't script the dysfunction
that goes on there's nothing else for
you to know about us it's all out and so
there's no Bombshells one of the things
that the courts are supposed to take
into account when they sentence is the
deterrent effect and when it comes to
things like bank fraud tax evasion and
things that the Chrisleys were convicted
of it's sending a message to the
community at large that these crimes are
noticed that these crimes do not go
unpunished I've never seen two people my
parents be so steadfast in their faith
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith as for daughter Savannah well
she's putting some major life events on
hold until I know that they're gonna be
there yeah I can't get married I can't
have a kid and dad has told me like when
I start feeling bad for myself dad was
like it doesn't if I may not be here in
front of you he was like but I'm still
alive yeah I'm still fighting I'm still
you know you don't have to live a day
without speaking to me
[Music]